[MUSIC PLAYING]
ENO COMPTON: I want to
start by making sure
that we're all on the same
page, that we understand what
"open cloud" means as a term.
And I think it's totally
fair to ask, why do we care?
Why are we taking time
to talk about open cloud?
Before I do that,
though, this presentation
is really two parts.
The first part is I want to walk
you through some of the things
the Go team has been
thinking about in regards
to open cloud and the
programming language Go.
And then I want to
introduce to you
a new library from the Go team.
So first, these questions here.
What is open cloud,
and why do we care?
So let's talk about
open cloud first.
The idea here is you
write your Go application
or your application, whatever.
You pick it up and you
deploy it on one cloud.
And the thinking is,
if you've deployed it
or if you've written in a way
that follows kind of open cloud
principles, there should
be nothing that stops you
from picking up that
application and moving it over
and, on another cloud,
making minimal changes.
And that's really the core
of what "open cloud" means
as I use the term today.
"Portable" is another term that
you're perhaps familiar with.
And why do we care?
Well, it's actually a really
nice thing, as developers,
to have the choice.
When we have more
choices, we can
do the thing that's
right for our business,
for our team, for our
application, whatever
the case might be.
And that's nice
because sometimes
Cloud A is what you
want, sometimes Cloud B
is what you want.
Now, the diagram up here on
the slide has two clouds.
You can imagine many clouds in a
kind of multi-cloud deployment.
Some of you are perhaps running
some of your infrastructure
on premise.
And this idea of an
open cloud application
is just as relevant
to a team that
wants to deploy some of their
infrastructure on premise
and some of their infrastructure
on the open cloud.
For most of this
presentation, I'm
going to be talking about
it as if we're doing it
on public clouds,
but really, there's
no reason why you couldn't
do something similar
on an on-premise
deployment as well.
So now that we've
kind of established
what the term "open cloud"
means for this presentation,
and why we care about it, and
why it's a good thing for us,
I want to stop and talk
about Go, the language,
and I want to talk
about the cloud.
So Go is experiencing this
fantastic growth right now.
There are lots and lots
of developers worldwide
who are choosing
the language for
their critical infrastructure.
And they're deploying
it on the cloud.
There's a lot of fantastic
open source projects
that are written in Go.
Kubernetes, Docker, Istio are a
couple of well-known examples.
And it turns out, Go is
just such a fun language.
I mean, I think, as
developers, that's
probably the most important
thing-- it's fun to write Go.
So as a result
right now, there's
an estimated 1 million
developers worldwide using Go.
And many businesses are
choosing this language
to deploy their critical
infrastructure on it.
And so it's just
a fantastic choice
for your cloud workloads.
But recently the Go team has
been doing customer interviews
and thinking about
how we can make
Go a better language, how we
can make it a better ecosystem.
What can we do to continue to
help drive the growth of Go?
And so when this concept
of open cloud came up,
there was kind of
this open question.
Like, what's Go's
relationship to open cloud?
I mean, we know that
it's a fantastic
language for the cloud,
but what about open cloud?
What about this idea of being
able to write an application
that you can deploy
it on one cloud
and pick it up and
deploy it on another
without any kind of significant
rewrites or anything like that?
And so that's the big guiding
question for this presentation.
So why is developing open cloud
applications so difficult?
It turns out that right
now, of the applications
that are out in the world,
very few are the kind
that you can just move
from one cloud to another
without any kind
of major rewrite,
major kind of migration,
or anything like that.
And so the question is,
why is this so difficult?
Why can't we just
do this right away?
And if you think
about it, the answer's
actually fairly straightforward.
From a high level, all clouds
are kind of similar, right?
We're talking about
virtual machines,
we're talking about databases,
caches, queues, whatever.
Like, it's all the kind of same
thing at the end of the day.
But the thing is, when
you get down to it,
every cloud is actually pretty
different from the other cloud.
And let's think
about why that is.
Well, first of all, every
cloud offers some set
of services that
aren't necessarily
the same with another cloud.
Each of those services
has its own APIs.
Maybe you're doing a REST API,
maybe you're doing a gRPC API.
Next, each cloud
has its own SDK.
So you have to learn that SDK.
And SDKs are built to
be able to do everything
that's possible on a cloud.
They're not necessarily tailored
to the application developer.
So these are the things
that you want to use.
It's kind of like
the kitchen sink.
And so as a team, you spend
a bunch of time building
ab understanding
of, like, what are
the APIs, what are the services,
what are the nuances of each
of those services, what are the
really useful parts of the SDK
that we want to use, and so on?
And you have to build
up that proficiency.
It takes a while to
really have a strong grasp
of what the cloud can
do for your application,
or how to use the cloud
just right, and so on, such
that if you wanted
to pick up and put
your application
on another cloud,
you have this tremendous
learning curve.
All that proficiency,
all that time
that you've invested as a team
to understand one cloud's APIs,
and SDKs, and so on
doesn't just immediately
transfer to another cloud.
There's a learning curve there.
And so what that
means is, as a team,
you get started on one cloud,
you're deploying your apps,
you're building an
understanding of the APIs,
the services, the
nuances, and so on.
And that results in that
you're probably still running
your application on that cloud.
Chances are wherever you
started is where you're still
running your code today.
So I imagine some of you in
the audience, or many of you,
are familiar with Kubernetes,
this really exciting
open source project
that's provided
a number of shared primitives
for container management.
And so some of you
might be thinking, well,
doesn't Kubernetes already
make this possible?
I mean, as long as
you have a Kubernetes
deployment and that
Kubernetes cluster,
it doesn't really matter
where that cluster's running.
So if you're on one
Kubernetes deployment,
can't you just pick
up your deployment
and move it onto another
Kubernetes cluster?
And the answer,
actually, there is
using Kubernetes is a
fantastic first step
to having an open
cloud deployment,
but it's also not the last.
And it's important to
think about why that is.
So in kind of an
idealized world,
we might say an application
looks like this.
You've written your
Go application,
you've put it
inside a container,
you've written some
YAML files such that you
can deploy it onto Kubernetes.
And then that
Kubernetes cluster is
running on some compute resource
for some cloud provider.
And so if you're thinking
about it like this,
you're thinking, well,
what's stopping me
from picking up my
Kubernetes deployment
and just putting it
on another cluster?
Isn't that open
cloud right there?
Well, as part of our customer
interviews-- and we've
been talking to a
lot and lots of teams
who are using Go, trying to
understand how they're using
it, what kind of problems
they're running into,
and just kind of the details
of how they're working
with the language--
we've learned
that teams are under
an intense pressure
to be shipping features.
At the end of the
day, that's really
what's valuable that developers
provide for the business--
we're able to ship great
features to our users.
And so while these
teams are fully aware
of the importance of
separation of concerns
and loose coupling
between a cloud
provider and their
application, in practice,
you have these really fantastic
services that the cloud
provider provides.
We're talking databases, runtime
configuration, Blob storage,
these kind of things.
They just end up
using those services,
because after all, they're
fantastic services,
you want to be shipping code.
And so the application ends
up looking more like this.
So rather than having this nice,
loose coupling between layers,
you have your application
and it's actually
got these little hooks down
into the cloud provider.
So inside your
application code, you
have some particular
SDK invocations
that are maybe calling out
to the database, or the Blob
storage, or whatever.
And so as a result,
your nice Go application
now has this knowledge about
the underlying cloud provider,
which really prevents you from
picking it up and moving it
onto another cloud.
And so what that means is if
you want to write your app such
that you can deploy
it on multiple clouds,
you have kind of two
unpalatable choices.
You can either rewrite
it, which we all
know that's a tremendous risk.
It's also very expensive.
Or you can not do it at
all, which means, well,
now you've kind of thrown
the whole idea of having
a multi-cloud deployment
out the window.
And this is one of
the major takeaways
we've heard from
a lot of teams who
are using Go in production for
their critical applications.
So let's think about this.
We're developers.
We solve problems.
What can we do about this?
Well, as a developer,
you might say, well,
wouldn't it be nice if all cloud
providers had a fixed API such
that we write our code
to that particular API
and then when we want to
put them in another cloud,
we can just go over there.
We have a standard set of APIs.
That would be kind of
nice, and it's probably not
going to happen.
And that's actually pretty
fair, if you think about it.
Every cloud provider is busy
building the best services they
can, the best SDKs they can.
And they just don't
have time to be
looking over their shoulders,
thinking about standardization
efforts.
So that idea is out the window.
As a kind of side note,
it's also really great
to have the choice.
I mean, again, the
whole idea of open cloud
is having the choice.
You want to have the choice to
put your code on whatever cloud
makes sense to you, to your
team, to your business,
and so on.
And so it's super important
to have this ability
to freely choose, and it's
good for the ecosystem.
And then we have these
diversity-of-service offerings,
and that makes life interesting.
New service ideas are
popping up and so on.
So the next thought
we might have about,
how can we get this multi-cloud
deployment thing working,
is, well, why don't we identify
some generic interfaces?
Again, we know about
separation of concerns.
We know about loose coupling,
we know about encapsulation
and all these things.
So what if we looked at a
number of APIs across the clouds
that we're interested
in and tried
to identify some
shared APIs that
will work across all of them?
Well, it turns out--
and this is, again,
something we've
learned from all of our
customer interviews--
that's actually a
significant time investment.
And that means
you're spending time
trying to identify
design concerns
rather than just
shipping features
to your users, which
is really what's
valuable at the end of the day.
And again, because you have all
these disparate clouds with all
these disparate APIs and all
these nuances that are totally
different-- one cloud has
this particular nuance,
another cloud has that
particular nuance--
it's a non-trivial
task to identify
what those generic APIs are.
I mean, it's doable, but again,
it's this big time investment.
So again, you have
this pragmatic concern.
You just don't have
time to do that.
So that's where the
Go Cloud team thought,
we need to have something
better to fix this problem.
We need to have a library that
makes it easy for developers
who are choosing Go to write
open cloud applications such
that they don't have to throw
portability out the window
when they choose the language.
They have this ecosystem
that supports them.
So we just open-sourced Go Cloud
yesterday afternoon, I think.
And in the core, it's a library
and tools for open cloud
development in Go.
So what does that mean exactly?
Well, first of all, we have
this state of the world
right now, right,
where your application
is coded to your
particular cloud provider.
The idea of Go Cloud
here is that same idea
of separation of concerns,
where you write your Go
application, calling into these
portable APIs for Go Cloud.
And then Go Cloud has these
cloud-specific definitions
for your database, for
your runtime configuration,
for your Blob storage,
such that when
you want to switch
out clouds or you
want to deploy on
multiple clouds,
you have this very clear seam in
between your application logic
and your setup code
that's actually
working with all these
particular, specific clouds.
So we're starting with some
generic APIs for some commonly
used services.
That includes Blob storage,
MySQL database access,
runtime configuration,
and we're also
releasing an HTTP server that's
configured with distributed
tracing, health checks,
and request logging,
something that we think every
Go developer is going to need.
The project's open source
on GitHub, like I mentioned.
It's released under
an Apache 2 license.
As an engineer, though, I'd
love to tell you more about it,
but honestly, I
think the best way
to communicate what
Go Cloud really
is is to show you some code.
So joining me on stage
right now is Ross Light,
who's the tech lead
of Go Cloud, and he's
going to walk us through a demo.
[APPLAUSE]
ROSS LIGHT: All
right, thanks, Eno.
Let's see here.
All right.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Ross Light.
I'm the tech lead for
Go Cloud, and I'm really
excited to be showing you
just a small taste of what
we have inside of Go Cloud.
So I've got a terminal
here up in Cloud Shell.
And we've got some Go code.
And what we're
going to be building
and sort of stepping
through the code of
is getting Blob storage--
just looking at one
of the generic APIs--
and sending a Blob onto Blob
storage on both S3 and GCS.
So let's go ahead and run this.
I'll run Go Build.
I mean Vigo.
Ha, ha, ha.
Go Build.
All right.
So that'll crunch
a little bit here.
It's going to download
all the dependencies
and get compile going.
All right, great.
So if we look in here, we
now have a new upload binary.
And I'm going to give
it a picture of a gopher
that I had here.
And this is uploaded.
By default, this
is going to AWS,
so I'm going to do AWS S3 LS.
I already created a
cloud bucket beforehand.
And we see that we now have this
gopher.png file that's in here.
OK.
So that's great.
That's about what we do
with the AWS SDK right now.
So let's see how this is
working under the hood.
So I'm going to open
our main .go file.
And for those of you in
the audience who may not
be familiar with Go, don't worry
too much about the syntax here.
I'll be talking through sort
of the higher order concepts.
So we have our
main function here
that has our command-line flag.
At the moment, it's
defaulting to AWS.
And then we have
some setup code here.
And this calls to a setup
bucket function, which takes
in the cloud, the bucket name.
We'll get to that in a moment.
But then once we have
the bucket set up,
we're then using Go's
generic I/O utilities
to read in a file from
the local file system,
create a writer onto
this new bucket,
and then writing to it using
Go's standard io.writer
interface, and then
closing it out.
And if you have
looked at Go before,
this will look very much like
opening up a file to you.
So a lot of the magic of
what Go Cloud is doing
is all in this Setup
Bucket function,
so let's take a look at that.
And that's in our setup.go file.
So you'll notice that this
imports our Go Cloud packages.
It also imports the
AWS packages as well.
So in our Setup Bucket
function, you'll
notice that it's returning
blob.bucket, this generic type
that is coming from Go Cloud.
We are able to just switch
between each individual cloud
and return something
that implements
this generic blob.bucket type.
So in our Setup AWS
function, which we just ran,
it gets credentials, and does
other cloud-specific things,
and then calls the
S3 Blob open bucket
to get the particular
implementation that's
the generic one that we want.
We can do the exact same
thing with GCS and GCP.
So in this case, we start
off with getting the GCP
credentials.
We create an HTTP client
that's authenticated with this.
And then we finally just
create or open a new bucket
that's configured for GCS.
So as Eno mentioned before,
the critical part of this
is that what Go
Cloud is giving you
is this seam between having your
cloud-specific code, your cloud
provider-specific code, and your
generic, abstract application
logic.
So let's go ahead
and see how we'd
use this exact same
application logic.
Let's try uploading to GCS now.
So I will use gsutil ls.
I've got another GCS bucket
that I've set up here.
And right now it's
empty, because I
haven't put anything in it.
And if I run Upload and
I give it the new flag
to activate the new code
path that we put in,
I'll then give it my
image of a gopher.
And I'll run gsutil ls.
And look, there it is.
So what we've just seen
is this exact same code
for being able to copy a file
from your local file system
onto Blob storage with no
change in application logic
has just happened just
by changing the setup
configuration.
So that's enough to sort of
see the simple concepts here,
but let's see some of the other
aspects of how Go Cloud uses
this in production, because
this is just-- you know,
this is a command-line utility.
We're usually writing
kind of more server code.
So I've got another version
here of the same code.
So if we list the directory,
we've got main.go and setup.go.
And I'll pull open
setup.go, but it's exactly
the same as the previous
time that we showed.
We have a setup bucket.
It sets it up with GCP and AWS.
But the new fun stuff
here is in our main.go.
So if we look down
here in our main.go,
we start off the same way,
of having the cloud argument
of whichever one we want.
And then we have our
Setup Bucket function.
But then we use the
pre-configured HTTP server
that Eno mentioned.
So we set it up with
a couple of options.
In this case, we're having
a request logger, which
is another part of Go Cloud.
And we're setting it up
with Apache-style logs
being sent to standard out.
We then have a series
of health checks
that we could use, which is
really useful, especially
when you're running your
code against a load balancer
or inside of Kubernetes, to be
able to communicate with it,
whether or not your server
can actually handle traffic.
So we create this.
We assigned it variable s.
And then for the
rest of this, this
is mostly just a
standard Go HTTP server.
We set up our routes, we then
configure the server, we then
tell it to do the
listen and serve loop.
The only thing that's new
that we've changed here
is that instead of reading
directly from the local file
system, we're now
reading the data
coming in from an upload file.
We then read it in
and then send it back.
So then the writer and
everything else below--
so creating the writer, and
writing it out, and closing
it-- it's all the same before.
We just added a little bit
of HTTP error handling.
All right.
So enough of me talking.
Let's see how this works.
So I'll Go Build, as before.
Great.
So now we have
this upload server.
So I'm going to start
this off with GCP.
Go run that.
All right, great.
So we got our initial
message saying that we've
started a server on 8080.
Open a new tab here.
Oops.
That's a little small.
All right.
Let's run a couple
requests against the server
that we just had.
So I'll do the easiest
one possible-- of just
listening at localhost 8080.
And this gives us
back an HTTP 200.
So if we look back at
our first tab now--
not sure why the
font size decreased.
But we now see,
right off the bat,
without us having to do
anything more than just
saying, hey, we want it to
go to standard out-- we now
have Apache-style logs giving
us, hey, we got an HTTP request
in 200.
And if you were
running this on GKE,
this would immediately
be sent to Stackdriver
and give you immediate
logs for being
able to observe what
your application is
doing in production--
set metrics, et cetera.
So back over here.
Let's try something
more interesting.
So let's go ahead
and upload our file.
So let's say-- oh,
let's get exciting
and just upload our
source code to GCS.
I'm sure it'll be fine.
So I'll do
uploadlocalhost8080/upload.
Because I'm in the
wrong directory.
Ha, ha, ha.
All right.
So Go Cloud.
Nope.
Session Demo.
[INAUDIBLE]
There we go.
So I'll upload that there.
And it gives us
the right response
and says that it's 200.
OK.
If we look back
over here, we see
that it's done an upload
post, giving us back 200.
So if we now look
at our GCS bucket--
GS Go Go Cloud bucket.
Great.
So now we see we have
both the gopher.png
file that we uploaded before,
and we also have main.go.
Now, to just really
bring it home here,
let's go ahead and
try this server,
and point it over to AWS,
and do the same thing.
So again, what we've done
here is the application logic
of the handler hasn't
changed at all.
All that we've done is
changed the blob.bucket
that's going through.
So now when I go to upload this
same thing, running the server,
it runs.
We see a request log has
gotten through to the server.
And if we do AWS S3 LS, S3
Go Cloud Bucket, ta-dah!
Main.go.
So this is just a small
sampling of the features
that we have in Go Cloud.
I encourage you to go to the
GitHub website to see more.
Go back here to the slides.
So we've just seen Blob storage,
but Go Cloud has many more.
We also have support for runtime
configuration, MySQL database
access, request logging,
health checking, and tracing.
So this is all available.
This is all online.
And Eno's going to talk
to you a little bit more
about what you can do to get
involved and get started.
Eno?
[APPLAUSE]
ENO COMPTON: So thank you, Ross.
So I hope that
communicates the power
of having a very clear seam
between your application
code and your setup code.
Because when you
have that seam, all
of a sudden, this dream of being
able to write your application
once, deploy it on one cloud,
pick it up and deploy it
on another cloud becomes
much more feasible.
Now, again, these are
the supported APIs
that we're starting with.
There's still a lot to be done.
This is just a very
small step into getting
to that world where we can
have this beautiful open-cloud,
multi-cloud story.
So there's a ton of stuff going
on at the conference right now.
There's a lot of exciting ideas.
There's the launch
of native, which
is really cool, especially
in this open cloud story.
And a lot of interesting
things to be thinking about.
So as you walk out of this
room, if you forget everything,
I want you to at least
remember these three things
about the presentation today.
So first of all, Go Cloud helps
you develop an application
that runs on any cloud.
And that's the big deal here.
We want Go to be
this great language
to choose if you want to have
portability across clouds.
Second of all, we're
starting with support
from Google Cloud Platform
and Amazon Web Services
with more to come,
in particular we're
going to work to have
Azure support on its way.
And finally, we're looking
for feedback from everyone.
Understanding more how
each of you are using Go,
and how you're using
it in the cloud world,
and how you're trying
to achieve multi-cloud
is going to be a big
part of making sure
that the APIs, as Go
Cloud expands and grows,
are the ones that are actually
useful to the use cases
that you're all
encountering right now.
So jump up on
GitHub, check it out.
Here's the URL.
It's under the
google.org/go-cloud.
We're just starting
there as we're
thinking about as it's growing.
Finally, we've written a
blog post about it today
that kind of summarizes
some of the ideas
that we've talked about
today and walks through some
of more of the examples.
But I think, really, the
best way to understand
what this thing is, how powerful
it is is to actually go through
the tutorial we've got
up on the GitHub repo,
and try to build
some stuff, or try
to bring it into
your application,
and see if it actually works.
Let us know what works, let
us know what doesn't, let
us know what's missing.
We're doing all
development on GitHub,
so you can send us
issues, you can send us
PRs straight on GitHub.
You don't have to worry
about Garrett and so on.
[LAUGHTER]
Small thing.
Anyway, I'm excited.
I hope you all are too.
We're just starting
here, and we're really
hoping you can all join us.
And we're going to build this
great open cloud story for Go.
So thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]